[Musique]
joël maxime et toute la famille mahéo
sont des fervents défenseurs de la
sauvegarde du patrimoine à des
guinguettes il offre du bonheur de la
joie de vivre aux gens sur des airs
d'accordéon et de bal musette la
guinguette de belle-ile est une
véritable institution castelroussine
elle n'ouvre ses portes pour chanter et
danser et parler de ce patrimoine
marquants de l'histoire du monde ouvrier
c'est trop tôt
c'est pathétique fable
c'est après ce après mais merci quand
même merci
oui exprimés kamini en roue libre et
joël sur wii avec plaisir notamment
savoir avec un très grand plaisir est
bon qu'il faisait - oui il ya des
risques mais on sait djezzy qui vont
venir voir joël maxi mon père et fils on
est d'accord la guinguette de belle-ile
bon en tout cas à ce jour c'est une
histoire de famille bas au moins depuis
17 ans puisque nous sommes depuis 17 ans
une belle petite piste de danse ont un
cadre exceptionnel le côté palynologues
formidable élan justement toute cette
énergie est ce tu es là tu travaille
tout le temps est ce que ça vient pas de
la force ouvrière de tes parents tu as
connu sa balle où le oui je suis issu
d'un milieu ouvrier
il travailla santé regard vers ces
concerts
et l'aide comprenait des boulots
comment te tiens tu es arrivé ici à
travailler en famille c'était comme une
évidence une évidence pas vraiment une
apparent avec des affaires de campagne
qui doit attirer pas forcément puis
quand tu es jeune n'a pas forcément
envie de faire ce que tes parents font
et en arrivant ici en fait le cadre le
l'esprit l'ambiance qui régnait à b
justement m'a attirée par ce we à la
guinguette bons joueurs et tout temps
c'est moi oui
jeanine sundows nos clients gagnent à la
télé qu'il à jeanine je t'aime je t'aime
a repris les cours du mois
écoulé pour toi
solin comme une star
voilà jeanine tu vois en direct de la
guinguette de jeu lille voilà c'est
pourquoi ces cadeaux à dimanche dimanche
un bal devaient tous les dimanches denis
danvoye
c'est extraordinaire et des jeunes qui
viennent quand même oui oui évidemment
c'est une vraiment multijet relations
avec les anciens qui viennent pour
danser le dimanche mais tu as aussi
toute la clientèle classique qui vient
toute la semaine pour me pour siroter un
verre en terrasse qui viennent se
détendre au bord de l'eau tout
simplement
[Musique]
je veux
la lune paul rousseau bout des doigts
avec la mousse
je l'avais encore
alors comme ça tu as quand même une
histoire particulière qui est vraiment
très liées à celles de la gaillette à
mystoires des guinguettes parce que tu
es un ancien ouvrier es tu as décidé
d'arrêter pour te lancer dans la musique
ouais tout à fait à partir de 93 tu
connaissais déjà la guérite de belle-ile
on entend parler quand le cheval famille
je venais avec les parents des jeunes
est ici mais j'étais tout petit j'avais
six ans attendent un pour toi c'est
assez des souvenirs d'enfance et s'est
remis aujourd'hui c'est un lieu un lieu
où tu exerces exactement depuis avec
joël et marie qui m'ont fait confiance
maintenant depuis peu près 16 ans en 16
ans d'animation ingate est ce qu'il est
a vu des couples se former oui tout à
fait à beaucoup et avant tout un lieu de
vie un lieu de rencontre ah bah voilà
bah écoute alors si on parle d'amour on
se quitte avec une chanson d'amour
[Musique]
car on croit toujours
d'autant qu'ils sont par ailleurs
[Musique]